the ability to ripple water with the
power of your voice is the worst
superhero power ever so how is Tony
creating these watery ripples it's not
Tony's voice that's causing the ripples
it's hundreds of baby mosquitoes these
mosquitoes are in their larval stage so
they're living just under the surface of
the water and when he shouts they think
it's a predator and they dive it's rare
to see this because the timing has to be
just right
mosquitoes were only in the larval stage
for about seven to ten days while
they're living just under the surface of
the water eating plankton
the reason the mosquito larvae can exist
under the surface of the water and not
drown is because they have little tiny
siphons like a snorkel that sits out
above the water
Tony's screaming is so loud that he
actually creates pressure waves that
disturb the surface of the water the
ultra sensitive siphons of the mosquito
larvae can detect this disturbance and
that's what causes them to instinctively
dive down and try to get away now that
he's seen it once I love the idea that
Tony is roaming around the world just
shouting at random lakes hoping that
it'll happen again next time
[Music]